اكثر من عشره الاف شخص من الفرنه من
الاشتباكات في السودان يحتضنهم هذا المخيم
بمدينه الرنك في ولايه اعالي النيل
المتاخمه لولايه النيل الابيض السودانيه
حيث يعيشون ظروفا انسانيه بالغه التعقيد
وهم ينتظرون طرح لهم الى مناطقهم الاصليه
جنوبيه السودان
امراض كثيره
اكثر من اللازم وقاعدين وما في اي فائده
من القاعده غياب الخدمات الغذائيه والصحيه
اضافه الى اكتظاظ المخيم بالعالقين عد الى
تفشي الكثير من الامراض خاصه الاسهالات
المائيه بين الاطفال وكبار السن
ويتخوف الكثيرون من تفشي الامراض بعد
انتشار الذباب بشكل مخيف
وزير الشؤون الانسانيه الذي زار المخيم
قاله ان جهود وزاراته بالاضافه الى جهود
المنظمات الانسانيه ضئيله جدا
وبالكاد لا تسد احتياجات الناس
مقارنه بالتزايد المستمر لعدد الفرنه
يوميا ما قد يفاقم من ازمه ايواءهم هنا
بسبب الاعداد الكبيره ومقارنه بمستوى
الخدمات الانسانيه التي نقدمها تعتبر
ضئيله جدا لانك لو خططت لاعداد اليوم ستجد
اعدادا كبيره غدا حيث ان الخدمات غير
كافيه وذلك بسبب شح الموارد
وعليه يتخوف الجميع من خروج الازمه عن
السيطره ما لم تدفع الحكومه والمنظمات
بخطط بديله ومستعجله
لقناته العربيه والحدث مخيم الجامعه الرنك
جنوب السودان
اعطي
المزيد جوا القصص الانسانيه وال والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات